hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich bin gerade ein bisschen
emotional aufgelöst denn ich habe mir
gerade die best of heiratsanträgen
2009/10 angeschafft
ich habe bei fast jedem geheult und
jeden fall sind das super
voraussetzungen für eine neue reaktion
von mir auch zu hause die schau bei der
ca gar nicht um heiratsanträge geht da
hat mich respektiert und wollte nicht in
alte muster verfallen
ich war so stolz und erstaunt trotz das
könnte der anfang einer neuen beziehung
sein
andere sind glücklich
ja hat vielleicht doch ein bisschen was
mit heiratsanträgen hier zu tun dass
honda meine lieben freunde und ronda
hatte ja ein date mit sharon
und die beiden sind sich näher gekommen
und ich glaube die haben der gruppe auch
geld gekostet weil sich fans so stein
alle haben dieses wohlig warme gefühl
okay nicht eine so aber was hat haley
für probleme das haley meine lieben
freunde ich weiß nicht was die für
probleme schiebt aber die hast halt
einfach alles und jeden in dieser
sendung interessiert schon was die
machen ist so richtig super freundin
hayley wir schlafen trotzdem nicht im
selben bett zu gefährlich was ist das
schon wieder fünf vergleich meine liebe
lampe mir fällt gerade auf wie tief sie
nicht diese ganze geschichte ist hätte
ich auch nie gedacht der habilitation es
wirklich so und den verstand
dann bilden wir nie wieder sehen dass
unsere lampe glory
und ich weiß auch lori warum sie hier
sind um zwei wochen fallen ihr dann
vielleicht auch die kameras
[Musik]
als auch klar warum sie hier sind zwei
wochen fall da vielleicht auch die
kamera als auch die abrechnung
die haben ja auch noch geld geborgt ich
dachte das sei mir egal aber es ist
scheiße geld zu verlieren wegen leuten
die man nicht mag habe
ganz kurz die du hast der gruppe auch
schon geld gekostet mitternacht bekam
sondern sharon den schlüssel zur credit
suisse um sich besser kennenzulernen
aber eventuell ging da ein bisschen mehr
als nur bettgeflüster show zwar schon
gesagt die haben nicht viel mehr gemacht
so die wahren baden und so klar logisch
das kostet dann vielleicht auch mal ein
bild wir wissen ja nicht wie teuren bad
nehmen zusammen ist
oder duschen oder so also ich finde es
auch auf die abrechnung mit lana
gespannt hallo
die liste der verstöße beinhaltet küssen
unanständige berührung der
das hat nicht ständige einsatz der in
der alles wird als alternative hatte mal
die neben doch da sonst keine plattform
und wo bist du auf einmal jedes wort
sind sie als ganz zu schweigen von hey
was denn sagt es doch locker fünf stelle
ich wenn ich ihn und honda sehe kriege
ich kopfschmerzen
ich meine ihr wisst doch das uns so was
geld kostet für mich auch werte nur auf
die rechnung mit dem ertrag finde ich
auch also ich bin ganz ehrlich wenn man
in der chance und das wirklich ernst
nimmt und ich denke ich würde tiefere
bindung aufbauen so dann regt man sich
natürlich voll weil die leute auf die da
irgendwie die ganze zeit amrum lecken
sind und keine ahnung was aber ich kann
schon verstehen weil das halt nicht noch
warten aber jetzt sagt bei den endbetrag
sharon und ruandas handlungen haben die
gruppe 10.000 dollar gekostet
[Musik]
ich würde sagen ihr habt den käufen
nicht bestanden
durch das ihr keinen hatte zeigt mir
dass ihr euch weiter entwickelt habt und
eine tiefere verbindung aufbaut
ok es wenn was positives mitgenommen
allerdings auf 16.000 euro verloren
sondern schaue ich hasse euch ich habe
zwar gar nichts von dem geld aber
trotzdem seine freunde da so ein stich
zu lassen und sie werden dir alle leute
der schon frech wir haben geld verloren
aber mein kumpel sharon hat sich echt
weiterentwickelt dass sie allein in das
schritt waren und trotzdem keinen rappen
beeindruckt mich echt krass dennoch
würde ich mir denken 16.000 dollar
so alle haben über geschäftsjahren harry
gelästert aber das waren halt nur 3000
dollar
wo ist da der sinn um ski haben viel
geld verloren aber das war es absolut
wert
ja
komisch lage sind sie jetzt mehr
uns weiter und so fort aber dann fand
ich das bei harry und von jets gab fand
nicht also da fand ich haben wir dann
viel zu großen hehl drum gemacht
schauen wir mal weiter das preisgeld
beträgt nun noch 79.000 dollar nicht
schlecht verdammt nur noch 7900 für
jeden ich schnell dass also folge ich
meinem herzen und hole mir mein mann
zurück
er erwartet hier franchise
mit blonder sprechen weil ich dachte ich
wüsste wie der hase läuft sich aber
getäuscht habe danach kann sie mir einen
rat geben denn ich verdiene eine zweite
chance
ich wünschte das wäre dann eine
fünfzigste chance ich wünschte ich
könnte ihn vergessen aber es geht nicht
aber wenn du wusstest dass du solche
gefühle für harry hast warum hast du
denn was
fisch passt voller höhe bei denen ist
was ganz schlimme ist francesca beim
reden in die augen zu gucken schreibt
für die kommentare gucke ich das ding
noch irgendwo herum fliegen gehabt
leicht war es mir das gegeben hat was
ich von harry wollte es war da fehlt
einfach was verstehe ich brauche keinen
rat
ja also wirklich an francesca stelle ich
hätte niemals etwas mit kerze angefangen
weil klar harry hatte was mit dir und
ich hab da ein bisschen stress gehabt
und blabla erwarte harry direkt was
miteinander mädchen saß francesca mit
carols im whirlpool
ja ich bin auch ein whirlpool francescas
ich habe zu sehen was schon und ich
durchgemacht haben und so wie jetzt
deshalb stehen gibt ihr hoffnung
vielleicht gehen harry und francesca ja
auch den nächsten schritt gemeinsam
vielleicht gehen sie aber den folgenden
schritt dann wieder auseinander tag kann
ja dahin vielleicht ein video grad vor
ein paar tagen was die fremdgegangen
[Musik]
die beiden sind so wieso habe ich über 4
millionen abonnenten auf youtube gut
frage du musst harry sagen was du fühlst
egal wie er das sieht welche auch wenn
er nicht abreißt macht er nicht dann
meister wenigstens bescheid studie auch
wieder ins grübeln
ich bin gespannt auf die unterhaltung
gene sorge francesca deine zwei gockel
kämpfen um dich und damit meine ich sie
lästern was mit anderen leuten was mal
die
was die wollen sie jetzt gegeneinander
was machbar abgeschrieben und kelz gegen
sofort zum angriff oder behandelte er
die alle sei
herzhaft
die massnahmen whirlpool
nicht groß da irgendwie rum gelegt also
ich von cairns reaktionen eigentlich
stark ich werde auch sagen dass er jetzt
wie ein idiot ich mag ihn fertig harry
ich glaube wenn nur kerls fertig machen
willst dann bringt auch so einen rugby
schrei nicht der typ ist gefühlt doppelt
so großen doppelt so breit wie du was
für ein tag sharon da haben einen großen
haufen geld verloren
das machen stoßen wir hatten eine große
klappe und preis scheint noch großes mit
curry vor zu haben
da stehen wir nicht wieder auf die lampe
stehen kann heute war es okay du bist so
schön das macht mich nervös
von honda reden über gott und die welt
über ehemalige beziehungen und tiefere
bindungen und preis und die lampe
quatschen über gebrannt heute nacht
krastel mich so an glory keiner weise
mache ich erst mit dem album und lernen
dann kennen und dafür muss ich mich an
rahmenplan halten und erst eine
verbindung aufbauen
aber was ist wenn dann kann ich mit dem
sprühen ich glaube wirklich dass unsere
lampe chloe den sinn der sendung nicht
so richtig verstanden hat also ich
glaube in der nächsten folge wir
zwischen preis und chloe auf jeden fall
was passieren zudem mit auch das
gespräch zwischen harry und francesca
also es wird auf jeden fall abgeben
meine lieben freunde an der stelle wird
sich allerdings das heutige video erst
einmal beenden wenn euch das heutige
video gefallen hat dann das gerne einen
daumen hoch unter dem video und bei
50.000 likes suche ich mal einen trecker
ich weiß nicht ob ich denn noch habe
muss ich mal gucken aber seht ihr dann
in der nächsten folge und jetzt befinden
uns auch schon im auto meine lieben
freunde berlin noch kein abonnent von
meinem kanal seit um die nächste episode
luca reagiert oft uhr nicht verpassen
wollt dann klickt hier drauf das ist ein
smiley und dann werdet ihr kostenlos
teil der nook und jetzt ein anderes
video verlinkt das meine letzte action
auf touren